my name is Jackson from the wall toilet
organization I think that the there is
no joke political conflict possible
because people will then find the
opportunity to invest back home
internally and the they can invest India
poorer region to help oppose the income
gap or they could also invest in the
night economy for example I Singapore
there is no kuro region there is a
wasted economy time at night where
officers are empty roads are empty and
all these are national assets was
trillions of dollars and if we invest in
the mac economy then we can get people
to work at night because people don't
want to look at night when the family
lives in the day but if they move the
entire family into the night and this
night school this night shopping there
is my recreation nightspots activity run
the country 24 hours you can internally
generate enough economic activities
until the the new recovery comes by then
you might still want to work fish